I wanted to put you know I wanted a sort
of light touch because there were so
many stories I could tell in this book
and part of it was just a focus on on
the father and the son but memory is
never the memory is as a function never
offers the full story right it's it's
the way we remember things is never
obviously as they actually happen and
there's always a tidbit you know a
handkerchief a color a smell a wisp of
hair the the street sign it's always
something and I was interested in the
sort of inherently fragmented nature of
memory so that comes across you know
there's there's a scene in the novel
where he describes a sort of xerxes the
protagonist describes a sort of fear of
Ed McMahon he's horrified by him as a as
a celebrity he never knows why he has
such an adverse reaction to seeing him
on Star Search or um you know publisher
sweepstakes or whatever he did and um he
traces it back to the first time he ever
saw at McMann on TV his parents were
having a fairly politically charged
fight and then later in life he also
explores what that sort of symbol of EDD
McMahon meant to him and the sort of he
imagines drilling a hole from underneath
ed McMahon's shiny designer shoes
through the center of the earth and
coming on the other end and that if you
if you did that on the other end would
be the hands and knees of people who
looked more like him so there's a lot
there's there's games in this novel
there's there's the the conjuring of old
memories and then there's reflection on
the conjuring of memories there's a lot
of there's a multi-layered treatment of
memory how do we actually remember it
then how do we actually reflect on it it
becomes a thing in itself you know the
ghosts in the room
actually takes on some flesh at some
point